part of saving the world I think is to
make people angry to make people
absolutely furious with the way we are
being managed the human enterprise is
being managed by idiots and you know I
don't say they're then dick davidians
but the case could certainly be made but
give or take that they're idiots and we
we don't have forever you know in fact
we have I think a very short amount of
time to take hold and to insist that
human values which none of us have much
trouble accessing I mean I'm not saying
we're all Albert Schweitzer but we know
what it means to be Albert Schweitzer
why are our institutions unable to
project the human values that we
personally are able to feel and then why
do we tolerate them why our boy is in
charge of everything it just doesn't
make any kind of sense working our way
out of this is just going to require
shock treatment and that's what this
shamanic auction represents I mean I
wouldn't preach this if I didn't think
the situation were fairly desperate it's
it's a radical action it's not a
reasonable option it's a quick fix
because quick is the only fix that
counts now this is not a debating
society in the crisis confronting this
planet it's a life-or-death situation I
don't see any other option
[Music]
[Music]
you